bootleg cab podcast special guest in
here her EP Amy's World comes out on the
13th yes the new season of Love and Hip
Hop Atlanta that she is debuting on also
comes out on the 13th of June
we working here and uh we just did a
dope interview go watch it who never
gonna have to do what she does she about
to wrap her ass off let's do it we're
gonna get straight to it let's get
straight to it I like it that way
I like it that way tell me oh I see
[Music]
yeah
Okay Kevin you wanted a real female
rapper on the show of course okay
look
yeah used to be broke not cash on me
it's in the broke [__] about a whole
ass on me imma run up with your [__]
all this ass on me I just wanna feel a
little bit I'm back in the weed I ride
around looking for a little lick I'm in
the club making movies that's a little
flick your section full of lanes that's
a little lit I'm too busy I ain't
worried about your little [__] if I
pull up I'm only coming for the paper I
need my snack you bro [__] get it
later all this money I need four hands
to count it gold digger I make a bad
[__] bounce I hop on the jet come back
with the bengies ain't no room for you
hoes I'm stingy rolly shining bad [__]
you know it you hold the money but I bet
you won't throw it yeah
okay Amy a quick little 16. I like it
all right y'all I didn't want to go off
more but I Hey listen the EP comes out
on the 16th Amy's World and what's your
IG spell out your name and all that Amy
Luciani world all handles Amy
l-u-c-i-a-n-i World make sure y'all
check me out I'm coming I'm gonna do the
bars and the body's gay body with no
bars I like it we gonna balance both out
this year boom
hey I know you just watched a new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off here check out you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week